this peanut is not in Rolling good
rolling condition get me another P Bob
needs his next like whoever is the
person who is holding the peanut bag the
reserved peanut bag that person that's
his peanut Sherpa stick around
hey gang today's episode is brought to
you by our good friends at me undies
let's go me Andy's makes the softest
Fabrics you've ever put your body in so
you can sit down on the couch all day or
go out and live your beautiful your best
life your best or a podcast
one because I like a little bit of style
pattern I like a pattern show a little
bit below my belt line a little pattern
popping out great listen to get 25 off
your first order free shipping and 100
100 satisfaction guarantee go to
meundies.com DPT that's me undies.com
DPT hey townies welcome to another
episode of dumb people town
news
there are these people in this comedy
life these people these people in this
comedy life and world that we come
across that we get sort of
cross-stitched with that are just
memorable like we say this all the time
there are comedians big comedians who
are very very famous who I can't tell
you one of their bits and yet a stupid
little thing that we did with graham I
was going to tell you years ago like
lives to this day to this day we just
jokingly at a point in time when we came
out to LA and it wasn't we were coming
out to LA a bunch to like in 98 yeah and
then in 99 we finally made the move out
and there were a lot of people from New
York coming out and the question
everyone asked is are you out here now
are you out here now are you out here
now is he out here and then we started
doing about everything I just I just uh
I just had some taco is Taco Bell Isabel
out here now are we
they've been live streaming chalupa now
under the Hulu is live streaming out
here now actually yeah so again it's
like stupid
just to tell you so I'm getting dressed
uh getting dressed to go today and I'm
calling Randy on the phone no Amy my
wife she's like who's on the podcast
today I said Graham Elwood and she just
was working at the computer at and she's
like you didn't even look up she's like
is he out here now well here's the crazy
wife is doing the business this is a
real thing with graham though because he
was living on the island he's in Hawaii
are you out here where are you I
literally just texted in this like a
week ago I was like a year now
didn't I yes you did he just lived out
there just so that he can keep that bit
hard to move so I could be out here
again so I love that you're in and you
spent time living in Hawaii and you've
done such cool stuff amazing
documentaries documentaries all sorts of
you've always been just one of our
favorite people to riff with and hang
with and I'm so happy you're here and
the world's Dumber you know you've seen
it on you've seen it on the main
Continental you've seen it on the
islands there's just dumb Behavior
Thomas everywhere and and but you do
have a new special which we're going to
talk about we'll talk about that later
Jay we don't talk about that in the
first time we'll say this living in
Hawaii I think correct pronunciation yes
I think there's more dumb on the
mainland I'm going to tell you I I
definitely believe that no coming now
that I'm back out here now you're like
I'm like wow uh it's dumb it's really
dumb dumb I'm getting done here's the
thing we have the stories to prove it
our awesome fans here's the way to send
it you send it to us Daniel you just do
uh hashtag dumb people town at Daniel
van Squad Brothers on Twitter and we'll
know who sent it when and so we'll do
this one first story sent in By the
Great Carlene McDermott she be Carleen
here is the headline okay naked Brit
I'm already in found on Thai beach after
massive Bender with no recollection of
the last two days so they went to
Thailand why did you say a person goes
to Thailand have you been to Thailand uh
no you have not been neither of you
never never I want to go swimming I want
to go really I say well now I want to go
and I want to go put the negative this
does add to me wanting to go yeah I
already wanted to go so bad so now this
like this should be like probably right
in Piccadilly like this headline and
then Thai Airlines like it should be
like welcome to Thailand your vacation
time
genuine question of three of my friends
I would ask this even if we weren't
recording it yeah do you think there's a
is is there a bad time to go to Thailand
do they have like Monsoon Seasons I'm
sure they have a season where it's not
as good to go but I would to me it is
who was I talking to oh so was it
Thailand so I was talking to a friend of
ours whose family grew up in Hong Kong
and China yeah and they I want to say
helped build the infrastructure like his
family because her family was in
grandfather was in banking and whatnot
helped build the infrastructure in
Thailand and she was like Thailand to
that region of the world is like Hawaii
right it's like this well the islands
are unbelievable but it is like seen as
this like Thai people are so happy there
is this like general feeling of Island
Vibes and it's like this beautiful
wonderful place that everyone in that
region is like that's my vacation right
so this our friend Michelle was like
this is that growing up for me was like
this is our happy place and our family
was my like that's our heavy place so
understand that do some street food get
a custom suit everybody tells me they
get custom suits custom suit baby all
right in a situation straight out of The
Hangover a naked Brit isn't that out of
The Hangover it was discovered on a Thai
beach with no memory of what happened on
a two-day Bender so basically this is
drunk Memento okay
John G drunk Mento with just various
tattoos the freshmaker
the unidentified man and we'll figure
out how the regret maker the regret
maker we'll we'll figure out how old he
is later okay I'll give you the whole
story check the rings on his penis yeah
exactly is that right does that work it
does no that's that's true science from
Epson Surrey uh had been celebrating his
birthday with beer and marijuana on a
sesh this is in like a beer and
marijuana that's it on a sesh that began
on the 27th of October I feel like
there's a hit there's a hidden something
else like he's not talking about right
these kind of people when they tell
these stories they're always like I just
had a couple beer and marijuana no you
didn't no you didn't something else
happened you were slipped to Mickey or
you decided to try DMT for the first
time something and they skipped through
that stat there's just like what I had
beer I had marijuana I sniffed a bunch
of ketamine and then a little more
marijuana what I mean what beer
marijuana I was just doing cocaine in
the morning for breakfast
beer and marijuana came with the eggs
but it was better marijuana it's called
Uh cocaine over hard
he was discovered two days later on
October 20. cocaine out here now it is
out here it is
um it's kind of transient though all
right he was discovered two days later
on October 29th by stunned locals on Ko
Samui okay
is like one of these I like it's Phuket
kosamoy they're like these that's where
you when you think about Thailand and
you see the beach and then the like
giant rock yeah that's like coming out
of the water and the boats going around
that side score okay sorry you tried uh
so I'm gonna describe what he was doing
and I'm gonna we're gonna all pumping up
each chair almost we're gonna all say
what we do if we came across this what
you saw and then okay so I kind of know
what Dan's gonna figuratively
live immediately stumbling ready
stumbling around
and singing football songs before he got
into the sea and attempted to swim away
oh buddy that's what he did Dan you walk
right to him and you're like are we okay
everybody man you know where your
friends are what does Graham Ellwood
doing when he approached that situation
singing soccer songs and one attempting
to swim swim as hard as you can bro go
for it
you're like the end of Point Break yeah
it's just like dude you can make it man
so you lose yourself when you find
yourself I become boating I become Bodie
from Point Break and I tell him to just
I go it's shorter than the English
Channel you'll be fine who am I gonna go
man China if you want it if you want it
if you care and how much do you want it
man bro you're gonna need to actually
Loop up and go north but whatever man
this is the guy you did a 10 year old
girl just did that swim yeah yeah if you
care about the Arsenal Football Club
then do it yeah I don't know are you a
gunner or are you not are you really
you're a gun or are you a loser I'm a
gunner I'm a
swimming drunker
I get my drugs up in the Sun
the man had been in the country
48 hours
while he was swimming
the man had been in the country for a
wedding
[Laughter]
his wedding oh I guess
where's Nigel no he ruined you know he
ruined a friend you worry about they
were like thank God
this is the the wife said I told you and
this is the husband going I thought he
was I thought he said he told me he was
he said he got sober that wouldn't it be
great if it's her friend yeah he's like
this dude still roommates
you know how many weddings I've been at
the back table
was traveling on a tourist visa while a
fisherman attempted to help the man when
he was in the water he allegedly became
aggressive and screaming that he wanted
to go and meet with God there is no way
it's just beer and weed there's no way
he was on an Ayahuasca just been like
something Journey but despite his
protest the fisherman was able to save
him by pulling the man out into the
coast
[Music]
right he he's like get up here fighting
Harpoon him right in the ass and then
bring him over here
yelling he can't breathe yeah look at
that Jay
it's a [__] wheel Jay Bro Look at
that he's fighting James already based
on just all the water element this is
better than Avatar 2.
shorter yeah right has anybody done
better at atar and Avatar matchup that's
that the Avatar Avatar come on I'm in
this I'll come back I just hope too that
this guy sounds like doesn't mean being
a film nerd uh sounds like bricktop from
snatch that guy that just like
a pig can eat over 40 pounds
but despite his protest the fisherman
was able to see him but put him on the
coast of uh mean and beach where he was
found naked by the police I'm just gonna
show you a picture of him naked with the
police surrounding him there he is right
you just see him all right he had pretty
good timeline I mean I love a good tan
line two days of just when did the
clothes come off when did he was he just
naked on the beach for a long time just
beer and weed he didn't go to that beach
alone
yeah someone left him there somebody
left him there somebody were like Nigel
we're done we're done right I just said
no this is the end when they attempted
to intervene the man told them that he
couldn't leave the Paradise Beach
because he wanted to meditate
don't we so he's on it yeah yeah yeah
you got to let the guy meditate an
interpreter just said go back to your
hotel shower and then go back to your
meditating that's what they said yeah
okay but the man we had reportedly been
drinking and taken marijuana which is
legal in Thailand so well he's not even
doing anything he's not playing the law
said he wanted to stay on the beach and
relax so imagine you're these Thai cops
and you got to get there and you see
this guy and you're like this is gonna
be my homework on some level Thai police
certainly probably in this District are
like Daytona Beach cops yeah where
they're like come on buddy every day so
they have the whole conversation here I
want the Cheap Trick song to be the Thai
police
all right so that's the siren as it
rolls up on the beach in like a golf
table
man
yeah so he said I just want to stay on
the beach and relax to which the other
guy said yeah I understand but this is
not really the right time for that
you've got 12 policemen around you the
man said his response no I'm not going
back let me worry about getting back and
let me relax I'm coming here to go to a
wedding so maybe he hasn't even been to
the wedding well as far as he his
concept of time is probably he's a time
traveler Dad yeah Time Jumper Time
Jumper definitely Time Jumper Time
Jumper the man centers the Time Jumper
makes you crazy he was then taken back
to the local police station for a drugs
test you know a drugs test a drugs test
drug test we have drug tests here they
have drugs tests test which they know
it's many which
came back negative
the Brit was fine for public indecency
and he will be permitted to leave the
country when his holiday comes to a
close that's how nice the Thai people
are stay here for the rest of your thing
and then you can leave the incident was
has drawn comparisons to the hangover
and then they explained that the 2009
film that centers on a group of friends
who goes to like who doesn't know
Greenlee right Jesus but they end up
drugged and waking up the next day with
no idea what happened the film then
follows their time this is in the
article their attempts to piece together
what they can't remember about their
night out the fishermen who rescued the
man said I saw the tourists in the sea
struggling to stay afloat so I was
worried he could drown I tried to help
him uh into my Lifeboat but he was
aggressive by the way fishermen Heroes
catch a drunk man you eat for a day
man how to catch himself you eat for a
lifetime dying on that story for a
lifetime he's so nice
person is trying to make a living just
by fishing
drunk man flailing around the water
can't be good for the fishing no depends
on the fish that could be this guy's bad
all around but I think that's why they
go so you want to know how nice the
fisherman is this is quote I don't want
him to be punished I'm relieved that
he's safe now maybe he had too much to
drink and the weather was too hot for
him so he behaved a little bit crazy but
I think he's a good person this is great
this is the greatest
back to weddings as we are with the
story this guy is the fun Uncle at a
wedding who's like telling his sister
Carla like they're they're where are
they gonna go like because he got the 14
year olds drunk and he's like it's a
wedding they're here really we're
staying in this hotel Carla chill out
the fisherman is this guy he's
essentially the uncle at a wedding who
gets his nieces and nephews drunks and
he's like just relax
to the cops he's like who cares let him
go it's a wedding like really you think
he's a good person he's a damaged person
this guy he's the type of person you
should never let date a relative of
yours you never lend this guy money to
your wedding right exactly he's not a
good person based on what we've known
about him so far maybe this Fisherman's
a terrible judgment character all right
who you're like who they say wait a
minute you got married I didn't know we
sent you an invitation yeah maybe you
gotta you better talk to your mailman
because that went out to you like all
right after
we're going to end the first round this
has been a while we were surprised you
didn't write to us we were mad at you
that you never responded that fisherman
better be his plus one thank you I feel
like the fishermen also what's not in
the story is he doubles as the pull the
dead bodies out of the out of the harbor
so he's like I ain't doing that again no
I lose a whole day of fish I'd rather
get him when they're alive because then
you can get them out at a better time
because of the dead bodies kill my
fishing business I mean this is so for
him this is really a catch and release
onto the beach to the police it's a
catching police yeah
um so how old will end this story on
this we'll come back we'll talk about
Graham special talk about other stuff's
got going on and stuff we have going on
uh let's figure this out how old is the
naked bread found on the beach in
Thailand
two days doesn't know what happened to
him uh how old is he 32 32 what do you
think 47.
I put I put him in this rate yeah four
but like late 40s early 50s pick one 52
52. all right get interesting get yours
answers in get yours get yours drugs
tests done guys get your answers in end
of story one the naked Brit found on
Thai Beach we'll call him Nigel massive
Bender with no regulation in the last
two days is
30 years old
oh Daniel I love it uh we got Graham
Elwood with us we're gonna find out what
he's doing right after this break it's
dumb people Town don't go nowhere
scar Brothers what's something you look
forward to when you wake up every
morning putting on my underwear okay
that's okay I was gonna say getting
coffee and then putting on my underwear
I do coffee naked no underwear
me undies wants to be added to that list
they're already on my list with your
favorite underwear not just any
underwear but ridiculously soft undies
and prints and colors that make picking
out underwear actually fun yeah oh yes
yeah you can get your own Super comfy
undies with 25 off your first purchase
plus free shipping on and free returns
meundies.com DP so I got the regular
under I get the boxer briefs that's my
thing no fly I go no fly I got no flies
I'm in a no-fly zone and I love so
comfortable so soft you forget that
you're wearing it you think you're out
there free balling in this universe
that's right I completely agree guys
they make the softest Fabrics you've
ever put on your body and once you try
their undies their bralettes their socks
their lingerie you'll never go socks are
amazing Dan I had those ankle high
you can also sign up for the meundies
membership where you get a monthly
subscription that sends new Styles right
to your door plus you enjoy 30 off on
virtually everything that they make free
shipping and I already said that but no
returns on there we go on returns Early
Access to new launches and exclusive
member only I'm gonna tell you what to
do to get 25 off your first album free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guaranteed
go to meandies.com dbtj meandies.com dpd
hey guys welcome back to the show The
Great Grandma Elwood is with us he's got
a fantastic special out he directed a
bunch of specials uh he's just done such
great work since and I don't know if
he's out are you out here now I am out
here uh and uh we got to talk about
what's going on with us and Daniel uh
Dan you start off what what do you have
going on and I'm not sure when this is
gonna drop so just say it and we'll see
if it's after okay great
um on the 24th uh Irene two and I have a
comedy show that starts back up it's at
the cat's crawl it's like Melrose and
heliotrope nice so you can see that show
every other week I'll be at moon tower
doing stand-up shows we'll also do a
live dumb people town we'll say those
guests in a second but I'm also doing a
uh living week we are doing the living
wake of Big Jay oakerson we better get
asked and uh we better get asked to say
something and then the next week you
guys have literally done every once and
then the next week
um I'm gonna be headlining in Denver
with the grolics comedy guys and also
don't forget
that according to Jason Randy if we get
a thousand patreon members they will
take the hot chip challenge oh I'll take
that so if you're already signed up for
your contribution eight you're on the
spicy food I will like hurt myself for
you YouTube and then dude I can't I can
barely eat a hot cheese oh good I hope
you have to eat it in the meantime if
you join the patreon it's all of our uh
dumb it's your dumb stories uh scooping
around cinnamon us and we treat you like
only available on patreon that's right
that's why I said it's five bucks a
month simple uh we're super squads.com
I'm not sure when this is dropping but
we can tell you uh we'll be at moon
tower in dumb people telling guests will
be on the daily from The Daily Show and
Natalie palomides I love her she's
fantastic her special Nate is
unbelievable on Netflix and she's great
you know her from the Progressive
commercial she's so funny in those and
she's just a great performer and I'm
excited because neither of them have
been on the show before so we got that
happening and then our Target show that
we're doing there has got like Dana
Gould Andrew dismuke's uh Lisa Ann
Walters Lisa Trey bigger it's such good
people it's going to be someone Adam Ray
so I'm not on your show but you want to
be able to you want to do it well we
might have to negotiate it we have but
you're always I turned into a southern
lawyer
all right Dan if you want anything
you're always invited you're so busy all
the time you're busy uh and so that's
happening uh at moon tower third weekend
and then we'll be in Minneapolis uh the
uh third weekend in uh in May May so
that's good and then we have stuff in
the fall uh Ann Arbor and Springfield
Missouri check the dates it's uh
superscars.com very excited about that
Ann Arbor out here now no it's still in
Michigan Michigan stayed there I thought
they came out it's dry Coastal okay
um Graham tell us about special how
people can see you and all that yes so I
have a new special out manifest it which
is on all things comedy's YouTube
channel yes thank you it's only been out
two and a half weeks we've already got
14 000 views nice very happy with it get
it up get it up so uh and then I've got
tour dates the end of April I'm going to
be back in Hawaii uh April 26th what's
your club that you wear I've seen like a
lot of clips from you I'm assuming it's
from Stand Up Honolulu where Dan
performed right um and Andrew Youngblood
yeah you guys so fun is it a great Club
Club it's they opened it it's it's
coming up on its year passive
anniversary oh nice what's new it's a
brand new club there was you know
there's cool little places to perform
there wasn't a full-time club right Oahu
right and so this comic Jason pepper
started it he's awesome it's great it's
a great he's very common friendly great
when I was living there I could pop in
there anytime and I I would say it's 60
of my special manifested uh was written
on Oahu amazing I was able to perform
there and try stuff out and awesome it's
a cool thing because you get a mix of
locals
um my stuff's very political now and the
locals are very
pretty anti-government because their
Islands were illegally stolen in 1893.
were they oh that's so weird sure you
get you get you tend to get angry when
your whole thing got your land got taken
from you
um so yeah so I'm I'm doing actually
doing stand-up Honolulu April 29th I'm
doing Kona on the big island April 28th
probably April 27th and I'm in Arizona
in May uh May 11th Phoenix May 12th
Tucson you can go to grandma.com for all
the tour dates watch the special come
see me live ladies what's so special and
give it a thumbs up and then share it
with a friend everybody's like hey who
should I be checking new specials out
we're giving them to you this is how we
do it uh Grandma L word and the name of
the special is Manifesto manifest okay
check it out which is out here now all
things we manifested it all right Daniel
you ready let's go yeah send him by
Carlene McDermott Carly and she gets to
him fast here's the headline man pushes
food item up Colorado Mountain using
unconventional body parts
euphemism for up his ass
Dan when you said
first thing problem in my mind is this
guy I want to say
probably OD'd on Viagra so he's having a
priapism which is a never-ending boner
and that's right so he's pushing it up
the hill with the NeverEnding like a
wheel of cheese up the Colorado food
item you say a wheel of cheese yeah
giant wheel of cheese or rotisserie
chicken I don't know where to land on
this one it feels like maybe it does
feel like a rotisserie then you have to
eat it uh it's covered in gravel I think
that's part of the cooking Colorado man
didn't crack under pressure as he pushed
a peanut to the top of a mountain this
week so he used his ass Colorado Springs
president Bob Salem Marx
Hey where's Bob Salem oh he's pushing a
peanut up the mountain you know I ran
into down at the store could you ran
into Salem what's he doing well he's you
know running his own cars
still selling rental cars uh his vacuum
repair business went under him so then
he started selling cars Salem Suzuki
yeah not motorcycle what he's doing
we've got a peanut car for you he's got
aftermarket dysons he's trying to sell
you guys he does he does aftermarket
modifications to the rolling ball on the
Dyson Colorado Bob Salem Mark the end of
it I was just gonna say this feels like
it so then this is all if he is this
used car salesman this is all just a
yeah it's our it's our summer peanut
Sales Event well we're gonna push a
peanut up a hill at Bob's sale this nuts
to do it am I nuts or what he's sick
we're pushing crazy deals up a mountain
this Suzuki half price well Bob Salem
marked the end of his peanut pushing
Adventure when he finished his track up
Pikes Peak on Friday the man did most of
the pushing at night he told the radio
station and went through roughly two
dozen song about this and called push
and pee yes he went through roughly two
dozen peanuts along the way which nuts
it fell off the side of the mountain
peanuts are like the band menudo once
you're done with this you get a new one
in another new one it's like the Olsen
twin on a show swap it out swap it out
get the new nut you get a new nut in we
just hit mile 15.
this peanut is not in Rolling good
rolling condition get me another P Bob
needs his next like whoever is the
person who is holding the peanut bag the
reserved peanut bag that person that's
his peanut Sherpa oh God Salem didn't
use his hands to move the peanut along
the Route please tell me the man decided
to let his nose do the pushing oh my God
for the how many mile Expedition this
using your nose to push a peanut up a
hill sounds like a Biblical punishment
yeah yeah just that I worshiped a golden
calf so God made me push a peanut up
how many miles how many miles did Bob do
it I want to say
a Pike's Peak that's a long one I'm
going to say 114 miles okay wait wait so
he's on all fours I'm gonna say it's
four he's bear walking four miles four
miles I'm gonna say 10 miles okay
I think I went a little high yeah
no I'm sticking to it Buck 14 Bob's in
his nose but the man decided to let his
nose he was pushing for the 12.6 miles
on all fours bending over and pushing I
was 100 miles off it's an insane
whatever that is that's an insane and
certain times there's steps too I'll
show you Bob Subaru has a nose for deals
pushing up here's where you're gonna go
his nose had the aid of a quote homemade
Contraption which was a CPAP sleep
machine with a duct taped spoon on it oh
now wait a minute that's not in the
Bible wait is this this to me is like
could be the next mad
Max
right he's Bane or whatever
his nose that is Bane that is
he looks like a like an unfortunate
little elephant I mean the only thing
that God is no the only thing I smell
are great deals did Bob sell it so Bob
Salem Ford doesn't it look like
driver attached to his nose yeah he's a
little scooper this is not his nose this
is something on his face his nose didn't
push anything this is a misnomer they're
lying about what happened just like the
deals on a spoon this is how they get
you so they say 4 500 down and then what
they really mean is you also got to pay
for the distribution fee you always got
to pay for the title registration like
registration and the other fee and it
becomes 62.47. thanks a lot Bob Salem
all I want to do is get into a 19. then
you already love the car anymore like I
want the Mustang mock EV right this
feels like that whole deal like yeah
either you said that you had this Subaru
on sale oh we just sold it but we've got
this I could get you into this I get you
a CPAP soon I can get you into an
Impreza tell a lot about a person by the
colors they wear yeah he's got a lot of
Rags yeah he's got this guy and then the
one pink spoon that's where I that's
well that's for breast cancer
it's a Susan G Komen push for a cure
we're nuts to find a cure at Bob Salem
Suzuki and Ford dealerships now selling
e-bikes this is not the first time
someone has accomplished this exact same
feat in a segment on the second person
to do this in a segment on the mountains
peanut pushers what Travel Channel
highlighted Texas Craftsman Bill
Williams and his journey with a peanut
up the same mountain in order to win a
bet in 1929. okay so so in 1929 a guy
from Texas named Bill Williams did this
exact same truck with a CPAP machine I
didn't even know they had them
I have no idea
is this Billy D Williams
how much do you think that bet was for
in 1929 that he took and accomplished
someone's daughter
a plow horse say he pushed the penis for
like a hundred acres of land no I would
say like 20 bucks 20 bucks in 1929.10
ten dollars a 1929 I'm gonna go fifth
that's a lot I'm gonna go 50 I'm
switched to me
Bill Williams was bet he couldn't push a
peanut up the mountain in 1929 he took
that bat and for it he won fifty dollars
which today is worth
879.65
I thought you could buy like a car back
then in 1963 someone else did Ulysses
Baxter pushed the peanut up the mountain
in eight days to set a new record so
eight days but Bob Salem reportedly
knows his way up the mountain in how
many days so just to get this trade
eight days is what it takes to get over
a divorce is that right yeah
all right so
how many days did Bob's the record is
eight mostly at night going through
dozens of peanuts and moving these new
Ford Taurus he did in six days six
five five
he went at night which is just he just
picked it up and carried it nobody can
see yeah that's what that pink spoon is
a whole distraction so he's picking it
what do you think
Graham what do you think it was the
record I have not told you if he broke
it or not I think he broke it I said I
think he broke it but barely I'm gonna
go seven days
he beat the previous record
by one day doing it
manifesting it
all things coyote YouTube page manifest
Bob Salem who did the peanut push to
celebrate the city of Manitou Springs
150th birthday is the first person in
the 21st century to complete the push or
be that sad right the first person in
the 21st century to complete something
that no one asked him to do that wants
to do nobody nobody cares about this for
the sesquite Centennial how old
we will get out of here in this is Bob
how old is Bob Salem Salem
we saw a side shot of him you did he's
got to be able to like at least have
enough fluid in his elbows and knees to
like push it up the thing how old is he
what do you think
Graham I think he's going through some
mid lifestyle yeah okay so I I got I got
to put him I got to put him at at 43
years old okay I'm gonna say he's 28 28.
I'm gonna say Saturn is returning
speaking of Saturn
can we put you in this Saturn at Bob
Salem Saturn I think he's 49 years old
49. Bob Salem is if you get this right I
want you to walk walk out of here and go
straight to Vegas 53 years old
I got it this is him at the top of the
mountain wearing a code for his own
PayPal I assume and definitely scaring
the kids that's his venmo Bob you're
scaring the kids just take it off you
already did it you're at the top I don't
care Bob inspiration for the newest Saw
movie
he's got some sort of uh certificate
certificate of completion for him that's
the closest thing he'll ever come to a
diploma
wow there you go Story number two down
in the books Jay can you give us just a
little taste maybe the most violent
video game ever okay great that's uh on
the other side of the break Graham
Elwood is with us got a new special
called manifest you can see it right
here on the all things comedy YouTube
page let's get those views up let's get
them up over a hundred thousand we can
do it uh some people town right after
this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show Jay
take us home okay here we go this is
sent in once again by uh Carly McDermott
at chibi Carlene thank you uh I'll give
you the headline man makes VR headset
that kills the user if they die during
game what whoa that actually kills the
user let's get into it does it have a
poisonous plant in it what's happening
the man who created Oculus Rift
is that a fish album no the Oculus Rift
and the father of modern virtual reality
VR has created a headset that will kill
the user if they die during gameplay but
naturally quote does not have the balls
to try it himself yeah uh good that no
one should no one should try this how is
it gonna kill you I'll get into it wait
so so he designed that VR have you done
V you've done VR yes yeah have you done
VR yes yeah I've done it too it's like
fascinating and cool we did a VR thing
for like they were Major League Baseball
was doing something where you could sit
in on the bench during a game you can
watch your MLB game and sit on the bench
and you're watching what's going on in
The Dugout as the game's going on you
look up on the field and you can watch
from their point of view it's awesome
and then pop around the stadium it was
very very cool uh this does not sound
cool no this sounds terrifying yeah uh
Palmer lucky the guy's name is lucky
yeah okay Palmer you feeling lucky today
uh who sold Oculus to Facebook's book in
2014 for how much money oh Oculus this
Rich prick sell
700 million Daniel
I'm Graham but thank you oh he's I'm
sorry yeah
1.3 billion dollars 1.3 billion 2
billion 2 billion right it says 2
billion one of you is exactly oh God so
now you can decide
that'd be crazy to be so specific and
right so I feel like it's got to be two
on two or two billion I'll stick with me
stick I gotta stay dick you've been hot
all day all right get your answers in
shout out your ham radios because he
sold Oculus to Facebook in 2014 for two
billion whoa oh Randall's car and the
money that's right so peanut up the hill
on that one hey uh so he made the Deadly
Device to commemorate the anime Sword
Art Online Sao again Mark Zuckerberg
used Oculus Tech as the foundation for
meta so for those who don't know this
guy is Tech is everywhere he's made so
much money this is like the McAfee virus
guy like the right is it the Mac yeah
like that he like have you seen a
documentary he's like murdered someone
it's a crazy thing these two eaters go
nuts I think this is the and they're all
into like you know Eugenics so he's
probably just saying well we need to
eliminate the planet so so I can have
more Yachts yes yeah so let's get people
to kill themselves so there's that
aspect of it and I also think when you
get to that place where you have that
much money there are only a few people
you can you can ever hang out with
there's like no one understands what
you're a billionaire and genuinely
wanted to do stand-up comedy
would you sell tickets no right every
ticket would be free yes I mean people
could the venue still needs to make sure
you could even send you enough money for
the weekend too if you really wanted to
so they don't you'd be like hey come to
my show food and drink is free I've paid
the venue but that changes everything
everything because people so when people
decide okay this is what I want to do we
feel this way we go see concerts and
stuff like that just saw Billy Joel and
Stevie Nicks and it costs money my wife
and I went to go see it and I'm like it
costs money but I was like we're paying
for this experience yes this experience
is great and yes I parked at The Forum
at a point in time where they didn't
check me and I didn't have to pay for
parking and that felt great but I'm just
saying that like parking scams yeah it's
so crazy because even if you're a better
like what you're saying if you don't
sell tickets there's no skin in the game
people would just walk in we all know
this oh yeah the free paper and
audiences we all know those are words
the worst because and they should be
they're not there to even see you I mean
I don't want them to be obviously but
like they know they're the worst like I
work to I think about those people who
go see like Bert Kreischer at like a
huge Stadium or whatever or go see
Thompson girl or whatever they're like
we are us even on our level you know we
want to pay our money we're driving this
distance to see this person so it's like
there you can't skip steps you can't you
know what I mean yeah maybe you just
charge 20 bucks a ticket and it all goes
to a charity yeah people still have to
the club I would have all the money go
to the clubs knowing these psycho
billionaires not if we were making wild
Deja Vu but if if a psycho billionaire
did this they wouldn't give free tickets
they would spend 10 million on marketing
to sell it out right and just so they
could say I sold it out because they're
nuts like Elon Musk hosting uh SNL no
you didn't do as well as you thought you
did okay right your staff is paid to
kiss your ass that's right they're
telling you it's good all right Lucky's
killer headset looks like a metaquest
pro hooked up with three explosives like
a medical question because that's what I
was thinking explosive charges I was
picturing like something just kind of
just right in the background no three
hooked up with three explosive charge
modules that sit above the screen so I
guess it's on this it's going to blow up
your face right uh have you guys seen
John Wick John Wick the fourth it's like
a bond video I've never seen have you
seen the other three oh yeah yeah I love
John Wayne okay so I've never seen it
just started watching John Wick this
week because I'm gonna watch I'm gonna
go to the theater and watch four when it
premieres yeah but I'm like watching it
and I'm just like I have never in my
entire life wanted to see someone shoot
more people in the face shoot him in the
face shoot them in the face they deserve
it you do a dog don't tell me let me
tell you I haven't seen it yet but let
me tell you I was watching The Bachelor
last night and I was saying the same
thing thank you
uh all right so the charges are aimed
directly at the user's forebrain if
activated would kill the user boom
explosion the idea of tying your real
life to your virtual Avatar is always
fascinated me okay shut up you rich
prick you instantly raised the stakes to
the maximum level and force people to
fundamentally rethink how they interact
with the virtual world and the players
inside of it lucky Road that's what you
want you don't you think people are
interacting with the virtual world in a
bad way and so we got to correct it this
is what he said pumped up Graphics might
make a game look more real but the only
threat of serious concept only the
threat of serious consequences can make
a game feel real to you and every other
person in the this this guy needs to be
jailed jail no jail locked up for sure
like I'm from if this thing goes to
Market I'm never putting a VR headset
ever now I don't trust VR anymore I'm
never doing it what if this is the what
if he what if I got the wrong one I'm
never putting one on my head ever
because this guy's gonna blow me I got
the Oculus 356. in Sao players put on uh
put on a Nate and Neve gear or Nev gear
virtual reality headset and log into a
new game only discover a mad scientist
has trap them in a virtual world players
then have to fight their way through a
hundred floor dungeon to escape if they
die in real life this is just a final
destination I'm trying to think of like
the word sort of physical thing you
could do and ready everybody is too much
to me like if you got punched in the
stomach if you die still too much still
obviously punch in the face too much too
much what if somebody like what if it
was just to [__] you in the back with a
damn electric electric shock from the
unit wasn't it explosion was like an
electric shock that would give me a good
level of anxiety I could handle that I'm
saying that would really up it'd be like
if I fall off this clip I'm gonna get
shot I'm gonna get shot that would be
enough
for me to society's collapsing we're all
going to be in a post-apocalyptic
nightmare soon enough so we don't need a
VR life or death scenario we're gonna
this guy lives in Hawaii
and we'll be right back we'll be right
back now we're going to be murdering
each other for water go to manifest it
down
comedy exactly he said the good news is
that we are halfway to making a true
nerve gear the bad news is that so far
I've only figured out the half that
kills you lucky said oh my God I'm glad
you haven't figured I'm glad you haven't
figured out all the tech on the murder
hat
remember when you guys made fun of the
dude with the oh my God Dan you're uh
you got this Dan okay I'll let it go
unable to replicate remember we when we
made fun of the dude well I know who you
remember I was trying to remember who
Our Guest was I was trying to remember
who Our Guest was
um but it was when you guys made fun of
the guy who made the [__] machine you
thought
you were uh you thought he was a
horrible monster at least he's trying to
make people laugh at least he's trying
to fit this guy I mean he's trying to
finish people off this guy's really
trying to that guy's [__] machine
doesn't even have teeth that's right
it's just for Comfort no it's just
unable to replicate the device lucky
opted for the explosive modular charges
instead trying them to narrow band photo
sensor that detects when the headset
views that the game is okay first you
try first okay and how many interns has
he murdered it's got to be cantaloupes
and watermelons right it has to be at
some point he's the Gallagher of VR
don't get in the Splash Zone he's mad at
it he's mad that he couldn't come up
with the way and the Gallagher headset
on your head by itself to kill you he's
like I found a way to hide from other
from employees regulators and contract
manufacturing Partners I'm a pretty
smart guy but I couldn't come up with
I'm a pretty smart tag anything like
that don't ever say that don't say that
let other people tell you you're a smart
guy
you're a dumbass these billionaires are
not that smart they're just rich kids
who stole someone's idea and then got
richer and richer
yes or even if it was theirs it's one it
was one good idea they had one good idea
yeah they lost it don't be wrong I'd
love to find one good idea one good idea
yeah you do you have a lot I'd love to
see what happens we already have a good
idea grandma on the show lucky said they
used three explosive charges he usually
uses phrase three explosive charges that
he usually uses for a quote different
project oh what's that [__] project
don't look over there don't look over
there what is that of don't look over
there
he did not go into specific details but
lucky is also the founder of anderill a
weapons and defense contractor which won
massive contracts with the government
there you go this is all in in Graham's
new special I don't know why
because it actually is probably versions
and tangential connections is exactly I
knew it it's it's for the defense
industry let's find out how we can
murder more people yes so we'll put this
crazy story out there for VR and and you
know someone over at Raytheon went oh I
like this this is what they're going to
do they're going to fly over an enemy
country they're going to drop tons of VR
ps5s yes ps5s and VR it's like Halloween
three yeah and then and then when they
die they're gonna get killed yeah uh I
have plans for an anti tamper mechanism
that like the nerve gear will make it
possible to remove or destroy the head
how many times has he started that sends
at a party and someone's like yeah I
gotta go I have plans for an
anti-tampering I'm gonna head over here
oh is it tonight I got how many women
that he's been with have have had to
hear him talk about the anti-tamper
mechanism while in bed with him right
well they're choosing to be there
they're choosing to be there like
they're really worth it this isn't worth
it when he pitches this thing he's
talking about oh we're going to create
this Android thing I always want to say
am I the only guy that saw the
Terminator movies yeah am I the only
like you're creating robots to murder
sign baby yeah come on man even so there
are a huge variety of failures that
could occur and kill the user at the
wrong time this is why I have not worked
up the balls to actually use it myself
you do it first buddy yeah you try it
I'm excited for you to try Street
Fighter why don't you demo it at CES
yeah let's watch see if you make it
let's see if you make it live stream
that please this douchebag that isn't
that crazy yeah you know what I will say
it is extremely dumb it's so dumb it's
you know why this is I love this story
is appropriate for the show because it's
a guy who thinks he's smart but he's
doing the dumbest thing in the world
that's it that's the scariest version
because there's the dumb drunk Brit who
washes up on the beach okay fine thank
you this is like what about the peanut
Pusher peanut Pusher we're all just
peanut pushers and dumb drunk naked
Brits washing up on beaches and then
this guy comes up and he's like I'm
smart let me try this thing that's gonna
murder everybody kill everybody
everybody this dumb world that we live
in uh the special is called manifest
watch it here on all things comedy's
YouTube page Instagram L word I love
every time we're hanging with you it's a
good time that's what it's all about
that's what life's all about and oh [__]
we gotta get back to work peace
stick around make a sound there's more
to people town
[Music]